what's going on is there something weird
about this smell see come on now oh you
son of a [ __ ] why am I in here
Oh yamimash is this why I needed to play
it are you why that picture too
okay I do not have it on me haha
okay that's seven and I just need to
find one more and then open the door get
on the floor everybody do the dinosaur
yes I don't know what will happen to me
but hello [ __ ] get away get away get
away
you thought I'm a [ __ ] huh okay I just
got
[Music]
Oh what do we got what am I looking for
oh no it's something I think I see
eyeballs where am i I'm oh don't you go
down a rabbit I will snap your [ __ ]
wings up like I'm not going in there
that's a trap that's cute to see war Hey
oh you startled me baby any locks that
are in good condition is gonna help me
our cellphones
hiram we're gonna be okay it's just
automatically oh boy
[Music]
hmm
stop it in your that was weird hang on
let me get an idea of what's going on
before you start throwing things at me
[ __ ] you this has been the random horror
reaction compilation thanks for watching
if you liked what you son you want to
see more why not subscribe to my channel
want to help the channel grow please
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]